hello everyone today i'll talk about
differentially oblivious turing machines
my name is elan kommergalski and this is
based on joint work
with elaine she consider the following
simple motivating scenario
there is a weak computational device
think of a laptop or some small personal
computer
that wishes to store and access a large
database
unfortunately the device is too small
and doesn't have enough storage
so it cannot store the whole database
locally the natural approach would be to
send the
database to some remote server think of
the cloud for that matter
and add to the cloud to store a database
while this completely solves the storage
problem
it introduces a privacy problem now the
server can just see the database
and all privacy for the client is lost
an actual solution would be for the
client to first
encrypt the database before sending it
to the server
store the key locally and only then send
it
to the server with this point it's clear
that the privacy problem we had is
solved right the server can
cannot access any of the data inside
database because we've been shifted
however problems start when the client
starts to access the data
it is well known that the mere access
patterns if done naively
leak a lot of might leak a lot of
sensitive information about the
underlying database
so to this end goldberg and ostrovsky
introduced in the late 80s and early 90s
the notion of oblivious ram
an oblivious ram or orang for short is
just an algorithmic approach
that probably obfuscates the access
patterns though
the observed axis patterns
in in slightly more detail what it does
in oblivious ram
it does something analogous to to an
encryption
of the access pattern itself so that
the observed axis pattern is somewhat
independent of the underlying data and
the exact mathematical formalization of
this independence property
could be any of computational
statistical or perfect
depending on the application in hand
and all of the oral constructions that
are currently known
work by permuting the data in memory
and continuously shuffling it upon every
access
so in terms of constructions we have
pretty great constructions
we can obliviously simulate any run
program uh any ram machine where the ram
is of size capital n
using only logarithmic overhead or log
squared overhead depending on the type
of security that we
aim for namely if we settle for
computational security
then using one-way function there is a
compiler that takes any ram machine
and translates it to a another machine
that implements the same functionality
but where every access is translated
into logarithmically many accesses
and the security is computational so
this is great
if we want statistical security we can
do the same i'll buy it with log squared
x a log squared overhead
so this is great and this is also great
because
there is a matching lower bound namely
the namely we know that every
oram compiler must suffer from
logarithmic overhead so namely
whatever compiler you come up with if
you
whatever compiler you come up with the
simulated
ram machine will make logarithmically in
more
accesses per access on average than the
uh insecure version so this was proven
a version of this was proven by goldrich
and ostrovsky
back in their original work and there
was a refinement
by larson nielsen a couple of years ago
and the very and even more interestingly
uh jacob larson nielsen showed last year
that
even very simple and specific algorithms
or data structures
already require logarithmic overhead so
you don't even need to consider general
general ram computation you can just
consider very simple functionalities
so in terms of upper and lower bounds we
have almost
to tight in some senses or almost tight
constructions however the lower bound
also tells us very bad news
he tells us that
we need to pad all of the executions of
the insecure machine
to the running time of the worst case
input because if we want to make sure
that all of the inputs look the same
in terms of the access pattern they need
in particular to run for the same amount
of time
so while it seems like the overhead of
of an oblivious ram is logarithmic for
specific inputs
it's actually it might actually even be
linear
which is very expensive so this is the
state of the art of aura
differential obliviousness was a notion
that was defined a couple of years ago
by
janet al and it's a meaningful notion of
privacy
which is a relaxation of the notion of
full obligations which is inspired by
differential privacy so that's good it's
some meaningful notion of privacy it
tells you something
about what kind of security you're gonna
get if you use that
however somewhat surprisingly we know
that general ram computations
even if we settle for differential
privacy or differential obliviousness
then still we need to pay logarithmic
overhead
which is this is kind of a this is this
was kind of surprising
and but
but then it was shown by
genital that specific tasks if one
considers only specific functionalities
that we only knew how to get with
logarithmic overhead
with full obligations now when we settle
for differential obliviousness
we have algorithms that the children
with only doubly logarithmic overhead
and while this may seem like only an
improvement from log
overheads to double logarithmic overhead
it's actually better than that because
this is an overhead which is per
input versus the logarithmic overhead
which we have in full obliviousness
which is logarithmic over the of the
worst case
so this is what we know about
differential differential obliviousness
let me just try to define what
differential obliviousness gives us or
what what
what guarantees so let's consider
in slightly more detail the setting of a
oblivious simulation
so in oblivious simulation there is a
cpu
which is the green box in the middle uh
it's a randomized cpu
it has an input and we think of the
input as
a sequence of logical operators logical
accesses to the ram
a logical access could be go to location
5
and read the content or go to location
10 and write some content
so these are logical accesses and logic
and every logical access is translated
into
a collection of physical accessories or
a sequence of physical accesses
and the physical accesses are done
through the physical realm
and the adversary is observing those
okay so this is the setting of
oblivious realm of aura and in oblivious
realm in full obliviousness what we want
is that
the observed sequence of physical
accesses tells you nothing
tells the adversary nothing about the
logical
access when we talk about differential
obliviousness
we consider neighboring sequences of
input
which in our case is just neighboring
sequences of logical accesses
so think about the given the left
sequence of accesses
take an arbitrary axis on the left and
do something else at that point
this is the neighboring sequence okay so
you can
uh you access the same locations on the
left
except one time that you access some
other location some other new location
and now we consider the two uh
two two executions one of the left input
and one
of the right input and what we want is
that these two inputs
will be indistinguishable for an
attacker so an attacker sees
either a sequence that was generated a
sequence of physical memory accesses
that was generated from the left input
or a sequence of physical accesses that
was generated from the right
uh input sequence and it needs to
distinguish which one it obtained
and differential obliqueness means that
it cannot distinguish
and more more precisely what we want is
that
is a definition of the sort of
differential privacy
where we consider any possible sequence
of
physical memory accesses and we say that
the probability that the
the left input sequence called this
sequence
uh this physical sequence is roughly the
same as the probability that
the right input sequence caused this
physical active sequence
that that there the difference between
these two probabilities is
there is a multiplicative factor of the
order of e to the epsilon
and an additive term which is delta
so it's really analogous to the notion
of epsilon delta differential privacy
so this is the formal notion
and this is what we know about it
slightly more detail
so i'm going to consider epsilon which
is a constant and i'm going to assume
that
our goal is to obtain delta which is a
negligible function
so i will not explicitly mention epsilon
and delta
in the work of chinatown consider the
problem a problem called
stable compaction so stable compaction
is a special case of sorting except that
each element that you want to sort
is associated with a very short key the
key is just one bit
and the goal is to put in the beginning
of the array all of the
elements that have the key 0 and in the
end of the array all of the elements
that have the key one
and we also want to preserve the
internal ordering between
same key elements so this is what
this is the problem called stable
compaction and this is what we know
about it so if
we want to get full obliviousness for
this problem
so this is just a special case of
sorting the best we know
is to run a full oblique sword
and this gives us analog and overhand
work
and here stands for the length of the
input array
we also have a conditional lower bound
which says that
this is that this is necessary i'm going
to talk about the lower bound in a
second
and the result it turned out was that if
you consider differential obliviousness
then you can actually obtain a stable
compaction
with much much better overhead namely
only doubly logarithmic overhead
and they also show that this is a this
seems to be necessary
so about the lower bounds so both lower
bounds here
are proven in something called the bose
and beams model
and the balls and beams model is a
restricted model of computation
for oram which uh ties the hands of the
auram itself of the construction itself
in the following way
it helps to treat elements as balls as a
pack balls
it cannot uh look at the content of
elements it cannot only look at their
metadata
then they can only look at the
associated key of the ball
but it cannot do any sort of non-trivial
encoding of an element so it can only
move bubbles around
elements around so this restricts the
model
and it gives a weaker lower bound
therefore gives a weaker lower bound
but it's still a meaningful lower bound
in some a natural model of computation
so this is the state of the art of what
we knew about differential obliviousness
what we show is a significant
generalization of this result in the
following sense
we show that any computation that you
can run
using a turing machine with
n steps you can actually do differential
obliviously
so let me just parse out the statement
there is a very classical result from
the late 80s of deep endurance fisher
that shows that any turing machine
computation
can be translated into an oblivious
version thereof
using only logarithmic overhead so given
a turing machine there is another turing
machine
that does that has a completely fixed
sequence of
transitions so it's even
deterministically oblivious
and you can simulate the original
machine and it does so
using only logarithmically many more
algorithmically many more
steps so the upper bound for
obliviousness is
logarithmic in and we show that if we
only care about
differential obliviousness so we only
want to hide
one transition in the in our execution
then we can do it in doubly logarithmic
overhead
and by the same lower bound as in as in
chinese sports and it does work
we also we trivially get the lower bound
for simulating general turing machines
and by using previous work that i
mentioned this jacob larsen ilson work
we also have a a logarithmic lower bound
for oblivious for full obligations and
the lower bound actually holds for
a very specific access structures or a
very specific data structures
and like i mentioned so specifically
it's going to be a stack
or queue and the significant bulk of our
work is to implement our
differentially oblivious steering
machine in the turing machine
as a turing machine and we do a lot of
a lot of work a lot of technical work is
devoted to preserving the number of
tapes and
other complexity measures of the
original turing machine
so this is our main result
one corollary of our result
is that uh for the first time
we show and that unconditionally
differential obliviousness
is easier to obtain than obliviousness
so here we present a specific
data structure it's a stack for that
matter
stack or key or anything else that we
know that
if you want to obtain full obliviousness
you need to work at least logarithmic
overhead you need to have at least
logarithmic overhead
but if you want differential
obliviousness
you can do it in double lg rhythmic
overhead and all of the previous
separations of this form were
conditionals so they were in the poisson
beans model or
assuming some other assuming something
else about the arm so this
result is completely unconditional
so these are our results so i'm going to
tell you about how it works
how the construction works how the upper
bound works and
i'm going to focus on a specific data
structure it's going to be a stack
for just for ease of notation but the
same idea can be generalized to any
turing machine
and so we all know what the stack is
right
you can push an element you can push
other elements and put another element
you can pop
or pop push push pop push and the thing
you want to hide is the location of
your head of the stack which is just
it just symbolizes how many elements you
have
so it's trivial to see that if you don't
care about security
you can just do it with linear number of
head movements so you can support and
operations with only
n head movements
and by the compiler of pip engineering
fisher if you want full obliviousness
you can do it with
enzymes logan head movements
and you can even do it on a turing
machine so you don't need the ram
that and the lower bound that i
mentioned with jacob larson and nielsen
gives
us a lower bound saying that a
logarithmic overhead is necessary
even if you allow it even if you run a
tool machine
so maybe i will just note here that what
we
we need the stack to be in an online
fashion namely that the element should
come
online for this lower bound to hold
okay so this is stack and
when i say that they want to implement
differentially oblique step
what i really want is to hide uh
to hide which input sequence i'm using
the left or the right
as long as only one operation is
different so in two
sequences i have here on the slide they
are completely the same except
the the the fifth element
on the left is a push and the fifth
operation on the right is a pop
so the input sequences are neighboring
according to our definition
so we want to hide which input sequence
we're at we're using
so we're going to use two tools the
first one is just an oblivious steering
machine
and so we can use the people even
hearing feature
but we need we need an oblivious two
machine with
a little bit of modifications
so we actually need to modify a little
bit of construction of different german
features it will not be super important
for this talk
but if you're interested you can look at
the paper we also have
a cleaner presentation or it might be
clear cleaner presentation
prevention feature so this is one tool
that we're going to need
and the second tool is a new algorithm
that
can estimate the number of items in a
step
while maintaining differential privacy
okay so this is what i'm going to talk
about in the rest of the talk
so we're going to estimate the stack of
the size of a stack
differential differentially private so
we're just going to imagine a pop
operation as as a minus one
and the push operation is a plus one our
goal is to just
count how many is to just sound those
numbers
and so namely the number of items in the
stack
is just the perfect sum of the numbers
until that time
okay so if we push 10 times and pop once
uh the number of items is nine
and at the night at that point that
depends a
time point the prefix sound is nine
okay and so we can almost use
a black box an algorithm which was
designed by
chan shi and song and work it out about
10 years ago
it's an algorithm that gives you that
gets as input a stream of numbers and it
gives you
the perfect sum of the stream at any
point in time
in time while maintaining differential
privacy
the algorithm works in some in some
fashion which is like a tree where you
put on the leaves of the tree
you put your numbers so if you have a
plus one you put a platform you have a
minus one you have a minus one
and every internal node gives you an
estimate
of some range
and that the the very cool trick that
they have
is that every leaf because of the tree
structure
every leaf only appears in the subtree
of only
logarithmically many nodes so
because we're using differential privacy
for every time that the node
that the leaf will appear in some node
will lose something in our differential
private estimate
and because of the tree structure we're
only going to lose like a logarithmic
factor per node instead of losing
something which is linear
in the number of elements so far and
it's not hard to see that their
algorithm is
just running their algorithm is
oblivious it is not
it's not sensitive to the value of the
number it's just doing some arithmetic
computation
and it also supports elements coming
online
and so one
one problem of using that algorithm
trivially is that whenever we want to
get an estimate
but just running their algorithm
whenever we want to get an estimate of
the prefix sum
it costs us some non-trivial factor
because you need to compute like a
summation of log many
encounters and this is bad for us
so what we're going to do is we're going
to truncate the tree
and we're not going to get an estimate
every every time step but we're only
going to get
asked for an estimate of the prefix sum
whenever we need one
which is going to be every polylog many
steps of computation
this is like a simple amortization trick
and here's how the algorithm works so
think of the input as
a sequence of plus and minus ones and
think of
that we're at some point in in the
timeline
which is this arrow so we have two
variables at this point we have the
estimated stack size which we denote by
s bar
and we have the real stack size at this
point
the real one it should be hidden and
we're only going to leak
the estimated one because we're using
their differential private prefix sum
algorithm
we we know that the result is going to
be pretty close to the
re that the estimated stack location is
going to be pretty close to the real
stack location specifically it's
something like polylobe
so we will not be completely wrong with
our estimate
but on the other hand this estimate will
not tell
the attacker too much about the
relocation so it will not be able to
distinguish whether we are
in a sequence where one
which whether we are in the input that
you see on the screen or one
where one location was flipped
so that's why it's okay to leak this
steel
and now what we're going to do we're
going to copy an area around the
estimated stack size we're
we're going to copy it to the side so
let's
let's say we're going to copy a location
which is twice bigger than the error to
the side
and the next log squared operations
we're going to do
inside that oblivious step we're going
to do
inside a completely oblivious oblivious
stack so we can use the oblivious turing
machine of piping during fissure
to implement the next log squared
operations
we're going to finish the next log sport
operations we didn't click anything
during those block square operations
because we used a perfectly oblivious
[Music]
construction and we're gonna estimate
again
at this point we can estimate again the
stack location and repeat the process
so if we just do a back of the envelope
calculation
because the copying a large area will
cost us
off one per operation because we're only
a we're copying once and we're going to
do inside log squared operations so it's
going to cost us
something like fundamental operation
inside
that construction the next
bullet is the expensive one we implement
the next log squared operations inside
in the perfect
turn machine or a perfect oblivious
turing machine
and the overhead of that one is
logarithmic in the input size or in the
logarithmic in the
length of the number of sequence of the
length of the sequence
and that one is log squared so the
overhead is going to be actually log log
of blog log copying back is again
offline amortized and activating again
due to our trick or trick of getting an
estimate once every polylog steps
is gonna cost us again for one per
operation
by just setting the parameters carefully
so overall the overhead is indeed going
to be something like n times
w logarithmic this is
in very high level how the algorithm
works there's a lot of details of how to
handle
multi-tape turing machines and without
increasing the number of tapes but
that's a little bit out of scope for
this one
so let me just summarize there are
uh the the bottom line of this work is
that there are many
natural problems for which obtaining
differentiable business
is much easier than obliviousness
turing machines can be generically made
differentially oblivious with just
doubly logarithmic overhang which is uh
which is something that we know is false
for a run machines
and it leaves leaves or open
opens lots of interesting questions in
my opinion
one is the first our lower bound for
that
our doubly logarithmic lower bound on
differentially oblivious turing machines
is in the balls and beams model and we
don't know how to prove it
unconditionally so
that's one interesting technical
question
and another one is more
is more vague but it's just to come up
with other interesting relaxations
of obliviousness and to see how they
relate to
full obliviousness or just
differentiably business
and that's it thank you so much
you